let's head to kabul airport now where
our correspondent charlotte bellas is
live for us charlotte so domestic
flights have been operating the past
week or so
what about those efforts to open the
airport for international flights
well they're still working to get
international flights up and running the
domestic flights are the big focus at
the moment the first uh flight from
ariana took off about a week ago but
this morning's significant because
kamir's flight just took off about 40
minutes ago to her they're the biggest
commercial carrier so real sign that
operations are starting to get back to
normal talking to people involved in the
airport operations this morning they say
about five flights are taking off each
day that i can tell you there are a lot
of people in the
departures terminal there's an arrivals
terminal they tell us that they've got
air traffic control functional up and
running if you can see behind me this is
the radar that was actually broken and
they've managed to fix it they say it's
not 100
but they're definitely getting there
making improvements every day so
domestic flights getting more momentum
you can see this plane over here this is
a humanitarian a plane that's in from
the gulf with humanitarian aid this
morning we just saw a military flight
also take off so there is
quite a lot of action uh on the tarmac
at the moment now now about three and a
half weeks since the taliban have taken
over taliban members are down here
patrolling they're involved in airport
operations but also working with foreign
allies the qataris and others
to look at security around the perimeter
in particular we've seen them patrolling
around the tarmac this morning so things
are slowly getting back to normal people
can fly domestically around the country
but certainly not at the levels they
were before
and i believe the taliban have
introduced new rules regarding people's
ability to protest
what exactly does that involve
protests have been
a key
part of the news this week here i mean
they were in smaller numbers talking a
dozen people 20 people 30 people but
then a couple of days ago there was a
large protest that was quite peaceful
for quite a few kilometers as they
marched through the city but then the
taliban as they came close to the
presidential palace they sent trucks out
started firing in the air people were
detained organizers of the protests were
detained journalists were detained their
cameras broken we know now since that
point there was another protest as well
and journalists were detained and
actually beaten under custody some
horrific photos coming out of some
journalists who were separated in uh
prison cells and then whipped with
cables their backs
lashed uh it's really uh brutal and hard
to um hard to look at type photos so
they are getting a lot of criticism for
that the taliban have since come out
banning protests but they say they will
allow some protests under a couple of
conditions those being you need to get
minister permission from the ministry of
justice you have to give them 24 hours
notice and you have to tell the ministry
the purpose time and place so it's going
to be interesting to see
if these if protests can continue and
what type of scope they give people
because for the moment they are really
cracking down on protesters and those
covering them
many thanks for your reporting charlotte
bellas there for us at kabul airport